hello my name is Peter Jacob see from
the University of California at Berkeley
I'm here at the Wolfram rule technology
event to talk about my research its
focus on graphene nanoribbons but and
our aim is to make electronic structures
out of graphene nanoribbons that can
rival our current silicon based
technologies but apart from my more
physical research and also doing
computational stuff I'm trying to
understand the electronic structure in
the quantum mechanical structure of
these nanoribbons and that's what I'm
going to talk about at this conference
Thanks thank you for having me here
thank you for the opportunity for me to
talk here
my name is Peter Jacobs II I'm from the
University of California in Berkeley and
I'm gonna talk about something
completely different I'm going to talk
about graphene nanoribbons so normally I
would do my presentation at a conference
where there's an audience full of
condensed matter physicists and scanning
tunneling microscopy experts but today
I'm at the Wolfram conference and it's a
really nice challenge for me to also
show highlights some of the more
computational part of my research but
also imparts hopefully some enthusiasm
for the experimental physics that I'm
also doing so I'm gonna talk about
graphene nanoribbons you see an example
of that here on the screen graphene
nanoribbons are narrow strips of
graphene it's carbon atoms in a
honeycomb
arrangement and what's special about
these materials is that we envision that
they might at some point even compete
with our silicon based technologies if
we want to downscale everything make
everything even faster even more energy
efficient at some point our silicon
based technologies will not be
sufficient anymore
and we need to switch to something else
and we think that maybe this carbon
based approach can be very useful all
right
[Music]
so just to give a brief introduction I'm
an experimental physicist from the
Netherlands originally started at the
University of Konoha
in the north and then did my PhD at
Utrecht University and since the
beginning of this year I'm now at the
University of California and just to
give you an impression this is where I
started this is where I did my PhD and
this is where I'm currently with this
beautiful view over the San Francisco
Bay Area can I go a little bit further
to the right because I had another
button where I had the entire group with
don't think that's gonna work
unfortunately I had another image here
where you could see the entire research
group the entire group of Michael Crowe
me the main reason why I'm here is not
because of my experimental stuff but
because I developed a package called
Mathematica and with that package I'm
able to actually do quantum mechanical
calculations of the electronic structure
of these graphene nanoribbons so this is
the package and it will show stomachs
some examples of what can be achieved
with that package I'm just gonna load it
in here it is so let's load it in and
this package is freely available on the
internet so you can just look it up I've
published as a while ago um so just to
give a brief introduction in graphene I
think it's quite well known already all
right so that's the that was the
graphing paper let me show it again it
was discovered in 2007 by guy Minerva's
Elif and it's this two-dimensional
honeycomb material honeycomb arrangement
of carbon atoms and what they found
specifically here I have a model of the
material is that this material doesn't
only have this beautiful geometric
structure but it also has this beautiful
electronic structure in fact it is for
its size it has the highest conductance
the best conductivity properties of of
every any known material basically the
reason for that is and now I'm going to
go a bit into the quantum mechanics but
if you if you don't know so much about
dispersions or soda and you just got to
believe what I'm saying this is the
dispersion of graphene and you can see
that this you have this point in the
dispersion where you basically have
these pencil tips touching where the
dispersion is locally linear and that
means to physicist it means that the
particles at that energy behave as
massless particles and they go through
the letters almost unimpeded still there
are some problems with graphene for
example it doesn't have a electronic
bandgap and that's why we want to go to
graphene 2.0 and it's the graphene
nanoribbons so we nowadays have a
beautiful method to make graphene
nanoribbons it was developed in this
group by sari and fossil and what they
basically do and what we have been doing
since that paper is we select a certain
molecule with which we perform a
chemical reaction on the surface they
polymerize and then at when we heat them
further they generate these atomically
well-defined graphene nanoribbons and
there's many more examples of
nanoribbons here as you can see so
basically you just select the right
molecule and you get a specific type of
graphene nanoribbon I'm gonna skip over
this but I think I made the point that
different molecules give different
ribbons and these give different
properties
let me show some of my own work actually
okay I didn't make the zigzag manner in
but they that's a very special
nanoribbon I made this hetero structure
at nano ribbon where you have different
widths and that is that has some
interesting properties for field effect
transistor behavior and nowadays we are
also trying to use even more complicated
molecules to make even more complicated
graphene nanoribbons which might in the
future behave
have very specific behavior maybe even
gear towards magnetism or qubit behavior
so I'm using Mathematica to look at the
electronic structure of these ribbons so
you've seen a couple of images where
I've shown the geometric structure but
I'm usually working with a scanning
tunneling microscope and that is a piece
of machinery which also allows me to
really access the electronic structure
of these nanoribbons so this is an
example here in panel C of this figure
this is a paper I published a year ago
you can see some images of the
nanoribbons which I took at different
bias voltages and that allowed me to
look at different orbitals different
wave functions inside these generators
so these are actually images of the
quantum mechanical wave function inside
a single graphene nanoribbon that is
what you can do with this scanning
tunneling microscopy method are
methodologies and as you can see there's
also panel B and you see basically the
same patterns there and that is the wave
function as I calculated with my
Mathematica package another thing that
we can do so what I've also done is with
the tip of the scanning tunneling
microscope I've lifted off graphene
nanoribbons from the surface with atomic
precision and in that case you can look
at the conductance of the through the
nanoribbons here in penalty you see the
experimental conductance but also with
tied binding with this method I can also
calculate the conductance through the
single graphene nanoribbons just based
on the laws of quantum mechanics this is
something else
so I've helped my co-workers with a
different project this is not
nanoribbons but this is carbon monoxide
molecules on copper but also here they
were able to look at wave functions
and you can see some wave functions
experimentally in a B and C and in panel
d e and f you see my calculations with
my toy Bonnie package and recently I've
made this two-dimensional nanoribbon
these interconnected nanowrimo
structures and also what's interesting
about these structures is that we have
for example these interface localized
states which I can then simulate with
Mathematica and I can simulate the
projected dispersion local density of
states wave functions and that's all
pretty convenient yeah this one okay so
if you look at panel e you see a
rectangle and you just count the number
of atoms within the rectangle yeah all
right so I'm gonna do something all
right didn't delete this before testing
all right you're gonna do something I'm
actually going to do a calculation in
real time and it should be relatively
fast so I made this graphical user
interface where I can just import a file
a molecule file and I have some some
optional arguments here I'm gonna set
these to it through and and then it
should be on this computer if I can
still find it I have an example molecule
here and then plotting this molecule is
as easy as using the function molecule
plot which I implemented and then soon
after my paper was accepted then I got
the news of Mathematica version 12
also having the functionality molecule
plot so I hope it won't clash but I
think it should be fine all right
and this is the first time I'm doing
this in version 12 so I'm I think it
might be doing something weird all right
anyway so what you then do is you I'm
not sure how this is gonna work out like
I'm gonna need to specify the context or
I'm not sure I was gonna work but yeah
yeah so I haven't done this with version
12 before and I'm gonna fix that so that
it doesn't clash with the new definition
of molecule plots anyway so building a
Hamiltonian is as easy as using the
function built Hamiltonian and then I'm
really a bit disappointed that I can't
show these these molecules in real time
but in principle I would also be able to
show you in real time how I can get a
whole load of orbital plots for example
and it's just a matter of I can do that
within one minute all right but you have
to believe me and just look at the
examples and it's and you can trust me
that in a future version I will deal
with this this clash so I have some more
examples of results
all right yeah it works it in version 11
no I don't this is not my laptop okay I
need to look into that anyway sir I just
wanted to show you a few examples that
don't require me to do the calculation
right now examples that I've done
earlier and actually actually I've just
copy pasted these examples from the
tutorial that I've written so when I
develop this package I've written a very
extensive tutorial 170 pages so there's
plenty of documentation and here in the
top you can just see what molecule plots
should do if you just select a couple of
different settings you can see an
example of using different basis
functions so it has implementation for s
and P type orbitals you see an example
of a levels plot where you can just
visualize electronic levels and and
where the spin-up and spin-down
channels are and which levels are
occupied and here I have an example of
isosurface plot where you can visualize
the electron density at a certain ISO
surface of this molecule I have a few
more examples so examples nanoribbons so
here I have an example of a basis change
where I went from one basis to a
symmetrized basis using the so where I
use a new basis to calculate the
electronic structure of these
nanoribbons and you can see that in the
dispersion diagram on the bottom right
where you see the dispersion in terms of
the symmetry groups of the wavefunction
so that's kind of special and also the
charge density distribution inside the
graphene nanoribbon where artistic
exchange some hexagon rings with
heptagon and Pentagon's and also you can
see some analytical forms of the
Hamiltonian for a few sample system
and what is what called some people call
it five seven graphene some people there
there's like few names for graphene
allotropes it's called hecka lights or
fad graphene I think so you could just
get a look into the literature a few
final examples so here you see examples
of dispersion plot2d of different
lettuces with different atoms here you
see a few orbital plots of graphite so
the three-dimensional material the
density of states of one to a three
dimensional change of chains of atoms or
cubic lattices you see a few orbital
plots of the electronic leap lattice and
you see the dispersion in in in K II
space of of a kagame honeycomb lattice
which is very interesting for metal
organic frameworks and the mathematical
logo itself is actually the dispersion
of a square octagonal lattice alright so
in conclusion the Mathematica package
allows me to explore the electronic
structure of graphene nanoribbons or and
nowadays even more because I completely
generalized it to allow any kind of
input and as you have seen it's a tool
for doing quite quick calculations you
haven't seen the full power of that yet
I wanted to do this in real time
that's I ran into some difficulties with
in principle I would be able to do that
in real time but at the same time I can
also public an also get a publication
worthy data out of it so it's more
general now it's available to the
general public because I published it so
if you just look up Mathematica or if
you look up my name you'll surely be
able to
to find it with that I would like to do
some acknowledgement and here you
finally still get to see the crow me
group so these are my my colleagues I
acknowledge from the financial support
from the Dutch Research Council but also
my former colleagues from Utrecht
University where I started developing
this this mathematic package and also
from collaborators of other groups in in
Berkeley and you of course for listening
to my talk
[Applause]